こんにちはー
皆さんはアドラースキーですか
もうバレちゃってるかも知れですぼく大好きなんですよ
もどってん僕にとってこの
長野県アウトドアっていう2つのキーワード
ちょっと大きいですねうん
はいたった一つのキーワードですけど僕頭ん中にはすごいいろんなシーンが思い浮かん
でいます
なぜかというと僕は7件でアウトだ特化したカメラマンなんですよ
でえっとすごいシーンが動い感じると同時にですね
えっとすごい可能性も完成ます
でその可能性を8ですね消化したんですけども僕の目線からちょっと7件を改めてご
紹介したいと思います
宇宙から見てみましょう
はい
はい地球の中では
汗
地球の中でも最も水辺宝エリアですね
小さなすぐにです日本は
でその中でも本当中心にあるのは長野県です
で山岳としてはすごく良いフィードになっております
その差額フィードの中に僕にはどう見えているかっていうのを写真で30秒間初動画
作りますよね
まずはこれください
もんなんすかー q まで
色紙額であります
ので案が来たん
すごい数があるんですよ
で寝るなー坂戸市デイ
どんな感想なんですね
普段は300
テリーが気になって思っん
起動
オフ見えてるのはこうなんですよ
5ん
これが僕になが見えてるなるわけです
でこれ全部僕が撮った写真なんですけど
ちょっと疑ってませんだ
だったんですでどうぞよく見たいのであの今日は僕が取っている裏談をご紹介します
こんな感じです
ございませんこれはですねあのシットオンカヤックっていう普通はスバル
ボタンですねけどどうするとれタイム性があってチョッパ仕上がって女子もうこんなん
ですよ
こんな
でえっと僕はもっとカメラってあの3410万円くらいするんですよ
だからこれ相当なチャレンジの撮影です
でさらに
これですどうしてもクライマーをカ国語たくて
あのちょっと黒子って続けてっ池を癒したいこんな感じの撮影をされるのか
パートは8ですね
布山に泊まって米保証取ろうということで
8ならスマ20度とか最高行っちゃうんですけどあのそれをたまって
を招待していますこのチャレンジさせ
で撮影もそうなんですけど僕体験をしてまして
プレイヤーとして
まあ植木ボードやってみたいとか
あとアイスクライミング氷の壁を登るやつですね
あとは乗馬でスノートレッキングみたいなことをいろいろやってます
で僕こんなことをしているのでまたなっちゃって
それはですね
the range くん
交通者ってメジャーに作ったんですよ女子のだっ
でさらにですね調子に乗ってどんなところでもいつでも行きますというふうにメッシに
帰ってしまったらとんでもないあの取材でが来てしまうようなたます
例えばそのまあ4日間寝ないでアドベンチャーレースを追ってくれとかレースですね
その中であとはなんというバイクを担いでこんな感じであの
3000メートルの山縦走しようとかそんなのが入っちゃっけ
でも僕はされ授業のことで行きましたん
ブーバーこれで多いのはまあし100万使ったりとか
している時に紹介しています
で僕はそんな僕が思ったこと越冬
学ぶ上で世界をれるんじゃないかなと思いましたよ
なぜかと言うと他の写真投稿の sns r のインスタグラムっていうのをやってる
んですけど外人さんからの反応は非常に良くてあの author
がビュー著ヘェーおりヤバイっていう高そう
群入ってきてあのはこれはすごいなと世界に通用するじゃないから中のケアなどだ
って思ったんですよ
でビジュアルだけじゃなくてですねえっとちょっと数字もする文正
ことです
みなさんこん3点は皆さんちょっと僕贔屓目になる理由見てますけど
サーバこれです
3大都市圏からですね9棟3時間
でえっ車で1時間のドライブって結構近いにいいと思うんですよ
3時間がいいってもらえばアートピッチャーだと厳しいようだなと思ってもらうと
と引いて店ですはい
50っていうのが日本百名山のうちの約50座が7件からアクセスできます
これもすごいさがフィードんですね
こっちらいっ
スキー場の数これはですね86ありまして
でこれ日本国内の25%が長くに集中していいですか選びたい本
ジャンプ蔵数119これも日本対2
3,0003千メートル級の山が16であってえっとこれも国内最多ですね
2税込日原せられるんですけども
パロスランダムなんです
道つこれ良い道2なんですけど
僕はエセ facebook もやっているんですけれども
みんな日々江東区を上げてくる中にこんなとこいってこんな遊びいたしましたよ
がこんな道具開発しましたよとか切り間遊び取材しても取材しても全然
もうタリアしかももうこれはにょ一生かかってもにょもいません
さらに見れないこれ僕自身の目線ですけど
8雪質なんですよ
こんな感じですんだろう
kura ですねあの世界からも実はジャパンパウダーでジャパウっていう愛称で呼ば
れているほど有名なんです日本を正すので
で越冬世界有数の募りぞアメリカカナダあった水設営でそこらトッププレイヤーが
聞けるとなる理由に僕も行きに山に登っているんですけどよく会社に会った時に言わ
れるのが
まあ美味いで押すんでな
もう普通に言われてそこでも並べですもう意見なぁって思いました
ん
でこういうふうにいろんな部分を確信して倒木が7件ってこういうふうに社員のいって
思ったものをちょっと作って言っちゃいなさい
これです
アウトだけんだかのこれロブも作っちゃいましたって言うか来ないしたっ
でもあるみたいなじゃないですよねえっこんなイメージで長野県を pr して言っ
たら元には楽しいなと
行きたいなーって思ってもいいんじゃないかなと思ったんですよ
でまだ調子に乗ってさらに作っちゃいました
ポスターあっあっ
これ訪問結局今日内気だったりしたん
僕がいいと思うんですよねこれあの東京も駅の構内とかにこれあったら結構いいたく
なるし
でまぁ東京はの仕事に行動さんだけ見たらいいなぁと言いながら
を指揮していたこんな感じになるんじゃないかなと思ったんですよ
で僕がここません歯の県の魅力にお前のる
の前の女になる理由がですねこうある取材があったんです
で僕5月2年間やってるんですけど最初の方に感動したと騒がれました
これはですねあのパイパンツァーなんですけど体験ツアーなんですけど何も使わないし
何も乗らないんですよ
なのにお客さんが大寒と違って何をするかというと干支のず白板
なんですよ真っ暗な林道簿30分間だけあるだけですで参加者は都会の家族
スタートするんですねマーカーのいいの最初は子どもたちが強いプライって言って親に
も視野についているんですよね
でずっと歩い聞くってまず概算がピタッと止まって
って
ピザの今気づきましたが今足元が砂利からウッドチップにたかったんですよ
網はもうや若い
うさらにまた歩いていきますそうするとまたピタッとか屋さんがたまってえっとじゃあ
皆さんここで1分間目をつぶりでしょ
で耳を澄ましてみましょう芽を摘む
そうすると
なんかむしろ声がきれいに聞こえてくるんだと高さってなるとか特に濃い
あと風なんだかわかんないけど全部ですよ
で見分けましょういただけるんですよねーさん聞こえますよ
ずつは動物たちもこういうふうに僕らてぃなので彼らも
ぬフェミナつぶっにょで
で応援し家に着いていたこのたちが急に自分の歩き出す
自分ズームのんですね
これは自然ってすごいなぁとありのままでもうとかなかつにとっては感動なんだなーと
思って
さらに8遊ばせ方うまいなあと思ったんですね
このガイドさんたち
ていましたし
実際こんな感じで本当にイメージ1で昼間
北いったんです本当にどんな場所なんだなこれかよってくらいの普通の林道で
する方だったりしたぐらいひっあるぞ猛烈な方がいいと思ったんですよね
カラビナ
二飛遊ばせ方うまいなあと思ったんですよ
だともう一つ遊ばせ方が上手いなーっていうレッスンプログラムがありません
これがパンダルマ技術くるという軽井沢で行っているものですけどもこれがですね
この
スキーをはいって統べろうって言うじゃなくてスキーを履いて遊ぼうなんです
ぜひ賃貸に8ボールをパンチ傷がつきの入って
ベルを鳴らしいこうという風に遊んでいるうちにスキーの各部に慣れてこういう風に
すれちゃうんですよ
これもまた遊び方うまいなあと
でこのたちにとってすぐ大事なのって楽しい失敗だんじゃないかなと思ってるんですよ
ね
でできなかったことを楽しくできるようにしていくっていう中には自分に自信が持てる
んでしょ
自分ができるそういうことも遊びの中からこの等では頭に来インプットしていく
嘘ことがこういうできるのでこれ遊び方も上手いしすごい実があるレスなぁと思っ
で遊ばせ方が上手い人たちというのはもうちょい
遊び方が上手い人たちもいるんですよな動きには
その共通点を3つ僕が見つけましてちょっと時ですけどもお伝えしておきます
まず1つ目山にはまず上らない
これは僕もそうですこの感じでスキースノーボード最初やっていて止まって楽しいなっ
ていうふうな入り口から入ってるんですよ
そうするとあのもっとでから登った
もっとだからでどっかであの peep 行きたいっていうふうに思うんですよね
実は今日雪としては山が楽しいというふうに入ります
で2つ目
アウトドアを楽しんでいる人ほどすごくしっかりしたご褒美を
キャンプとか山に持ってくるんですよ
例えば
このようなコーヒーですね山中電気するなように山中で挽きたてのコーヒーを飲むのか
あとお菓子お好きなお菓子を持っているとかそれによって8楽しみができるんですよね
メトロサティ女体しっかりしたあああっ
御坊
であとはですね不自由な場所を楽しむって目線を持つ
これがすごく大事で越冬先も電気水道はない中で過ごした時間帯
松の中というのはすごい快適ですよねお幸せなんでそれだけだそれを体験することに
よって普段がしやすい患者
これがまた楽しい一つなんですよずっといるわけにはいかないと思うので
はっ
かアティ動作ティ
しません
だから一石二鳥なんですよみんな楽しんでいる中で日の生活にもいろんな役立てていい
はいそういうそれをただ見にしています
でここであの僕もそのプレイヤーの人ですなのでこの冬行ってきた
ちょっと体験ツアーをご紹介します
不自由な場所に食ってています
はいいけばと思います結構深いです
あ
ここへと思います
これは二重ですよ
かまくらを作ってこのように泊まるんですよ
はい
でこの中に思っていますで今回は何をしてるかというと
大宴会大変
いっぱい持って行ってでまたグッズとかもないとこうやって楽しむんですけど
バーナーで冷やかしとかして越冬酒持っていってこれ以外するんですよ
特別感がすごく楽しくてねえこれ食べた時の
食べたのカップラーメンの味まあ美味しかったでしょ
でこんなそこでこんな景色です
待つばかり
舗装
僕にとってはこれもご褒美ですこの日に今っていうのも十分あります
であっ
雲海がピタッと止まっていっ
もう絶景すぎ
で朝食会場ここです
これ朝ごはんですこれ美味しかったですよ
で僕ここで楽しんでいるのはもちろんなんですけどこのアウトドアの中にはすごい大事
なことがいっぱいなと思って
チームで連帯行動をして山場遊びに行くという中にはその楽しくしたいっていうその
モチベーションでそれぞれが何か役割を果たそうとするんですよ
それらリーダーになる人がいればあとはムードメーカーになるような人がいたりとか
酵素が役目を果たしてすごい
ツアーというか体験ができるんですよね
それって実社会でもあの強いおおおい的なと思って
ある会社のオブジェクトをやった時には
じゃあ
自分はどの役割を果たしたらいいかということを真剣に考えて
ですごい仕事をするでこういう頭中のその資金ですねというものを遊びながらやるから
こそ女ちゃん本気になるんですよ
でそこで成功対決
あとの中にはその厳しい反面えっとすごく大きな価値があるんじゃないかと僕は思って
ます
大丈夫のっていうのは遊ぼうとするからこその学び
ここから僕も多くのものマン毛ましてで僕た蛇行写真を撮ってとかそういうふうにする
だけじゃなくてですね
あのみんなの行動をやっぱから学んでみるんですよそうすると愛舞う人すごいなく成長
したとか何か色々見えてくるんですよ
っていうのがだロケちょっと僕は思っていて
でナノケアですねむしろこの式であって凄く綺麗な景色が持ち上げます
でさっき言ったように遊ばせ方が上手い人で
で遊び方が上手いと思い
レーザーを目指して言った後
そういうなければやっぱりアウトドアの聖地じゃないかなと僕は思うんですよ
ちょっと今ロボ地帯ですよねいわきでしょうね
描けないですもうこれ行きたいですはい
で僕は痛いのはもう色々と言いましたけれども
チーズつ一つ
7件で
家族等
仲間ととにかく一緒に遊びましょうきっと皆さんそれぞれに対して
与作ガラスんでしょ